this week's [ __ ] that should not be
comes from Zachary Hoopa from who from
Columbia South Carolina he says my entry
for [ __ ] that should not be comes from
Hulk Hogan's magnum opus from the early
90s
mr. nanny I know if you've ever seen mr.
nanny Hulkster plays a former wrestler
hmm he's got range
who takes a job as a nanny for a bunch
of kids and boy that premise never gets
old doesn't it we've seen it fairly
recently No
yes we have mr. nanny from 1993 features
of the Hulkster on a motorcycle driving
through the the woods on his way to his
new job and I brought in the scene that
Zachary recommends it's if you look in
the background if you look to the left
of the screen when we show this clip
we've looped it so you can catch it a
couple times there is a guy in the
background as hope drives by on his
motorcycle who was really either a
pissed off at his dog or really really
tired of owning this dog they are by the
there by the ocean it takes place on the
seashore and see if you can catch what
happens in this [ __ ] that should not be
from mr. nanny
well that's Bowie
really inappropriate
that's right it's a guy drowning his dog
that's what you see a guy drowning his
[ __ ] dog
the Hulkster just drives on by he
doesn't give a [ __ ] his credit maybe
around your dog brother I don't care his
head too it was like letting the Hulk
Hogan do movies I gotta kill you before
he killed himself he killed his dog
[Music]
you